[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
the coroner says gabby potido died of
manual strangulation and throttling when
somebody in forensics says throttling
this is what they mean ahead a breakdown
of what the coroner did and why and
could the death penalty be back on the
table for the 2013 boston bomber when
was the last time there was an execution
in massachusetts the supreme court takes
up the case plus the federal mark gooch
is sealed here the jury's verdict in the
meta knight murder trial and later i
believe mr aubry's decision was to just
try to get away when he felt like he
could not escape
he chose to fight a look back at the
ahmad albrey case as we prepare for next
week's jury selection law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin guilty that's the verdict for
united states airman mark gooch
convicted in the murder of a mennonite
school teacher but first the coroner
says gabby petito died by strangulation
but wouldn't say more when it came to
naming the suspect in her death law and
crime's angenet levy spoke with forensic
death investigator joseph scott morgan
about the cause of death and how
petita's autopsy was conducted
brian the cause of death came weeks
after the coroner said that gabby
petito's death was a homicide he also
referenced during his press conference
domestic violence but didn't mention
brian laundry by name
the cause death by strangulation and
manner is homicide that finding in gabby
potito's death answered questions but
raised others dr brent blue said
potito's death occurred three to four
weeks before her body was found in the
bridger teton national forest on
september 19th that's consistent with
petito's van being spotted by the
bethune family's camera in the dispersed
camping area on august 27th blue's
office also released a document stating
petito died from manual strangulation
slash throttling throttling is generally
associated with the use of two hands and
you form a you know a u like this
joseph scott morgan is a forensic death
investigator and teaches forensics i
hate to say there's no other way to say
it other than choking the life out of
someone when examining potito's remains
dr blue said forensic anthropologists
were consulted and a full-body ct scan
was performed that produces images
inside the body i don't know
that the value of that cat scan can be
estimated and let me tell you why
bodies that are decomposed are so
fragile you go from a two-dimensional
world to a three-dimensional world so
you now can appreciate depth and
orientation
relative to
injury dr blue didn't elaborate but said
dna was taken from petito's body one of
the things they're going to be looking
at are the fingernails they did nail
clippings and nail scrapings and that's
gone to the trace evidence section at
the crime lab dr blue was asked about
petito's fiance named a person of
interest in potito's death and
disappearance but right now he's only
facing a federal charge accused of using
her debit card without permission who
committed the homicide is up to law
enforcement
dr blue said determining the cause of
death required some investigation it
wasn't obvious brian laundry's attorney
released a statement calling the death
of gabby petitto at such a young age a
tragedy but he went on to say that brian
laundry is simply a person of interest
in her death at this point in time gabby
petito's family meanwhile is not
commenting but her mother
told a news station in florida that the
words of the laundry family attorney
steve berlino are quote garbage brian
thanks aunt jeanette great interview
with joseph scott morgan as always he
breaks down more of gabby petito's case
and others on his new podcast body bags
make sure to check it out joining us
today is criminal defense attorney julie
rundleman and terry austin julie
everyone is speculating after
yesterday's presser as a former homicide
prosecutor what can and can't we
speculate about the death of gabby
potito
i think it's inevitable that we're all
going to be speculating i mean that's
kind of the job for all of us and i
think one of the interesting things as
you heard is that there was a reporter
that asked the you know
the forensic pathologist well is brian
laundry do you believe he's responsible
his job is not to determine if brian
laundry is responsible for anything his
job is to determine the cause of death
so we know now that that the cause of
death or strangulation i'll be honest
some of the things that we're
speculating about that i think we're
getting more than just speculating i
think we're getting closer and closer to
the truth is the belief that you know
these type of crimes happen with
intimate partners they happen with
someone that you've had domestic
violence with in the past they happen
with someone who potentially flees after
they believe they're going to be caught
and so these things are all leading us
closer and closer to potentially brian
laundry being the person responsible
uh
again time will tell
terry the medical examiner's presser
left us at times with more questions
than answers why can he tell us more
brian under title seven of the wyoming
statutes the coroner is not allowed to
say more basically he writes what's
called a verdict and he makes a written
docket and he can only talk about the
name the cause and manner of death the
age and the date of the death other than
that he has to keep most of that
information confidential and he said
that during the presser when the
reporters were asking multiple questions
he said by law i cannot tell you more
you have to go to the fbi or other
authorities make sense and how common is
it that a ct scan is used at an autopsy
you know it's not that common in the
united states although it is done it's
more commonly done during autopsies in
parts of europe australia and japan
it is something that is used in some
parts of the country where i live i know
the coroner has been looking to use that
as an additional tool and not
necessarily replacing a traditional
autopsy x-ray machines however have been
used for quite some time during
autopsies so it's interesting they chose
to do that in this case absolutely we'll
give you more updates on the gabby
petito and brian laundry case as they
come in thank you everyone on to other
top legal news rapper tyga was arrested
in a felony domestic violence
investigation the 31 year old whose
legal name is michael stevenson was
booked for an incident on tuesday in los
angeles the arrest comes after tyga's
girlfriend cameron swanson posted photos
online showing her with a black eye in
an instagram story swanson said quote
i've been emotionally mentally and
physically abused and i'm not hiding it
tyga was released from custody after
posting a fifty thousand dollar bond
and in new york a woman is charged with
the murder of her boyfriend's son after
allegedly starving him to death leticia
bravo was the primary caretaker of
seven-year-old peter quakus
who she allegedly locked in a bedroom at
her apartment six days out of the week
back in february koaka's father brought
him to the hospital after he was found
unresponsive he was dead before he
reached the emergency room weighing only
37 pounds peter had reportedly not been
to virtual school since january bravo
was charged on friday with second degree
murder and second degree manslaughter
the 39 year old faces 25 years to life
in prison
still ahead on law and crime daily the
jury reaches its verdict in the meta
knight murder trial but first could the
boston bomber again be sentenced to
death we'll take you inside the supreme
court oral arguments as the government
pushes for the death penalty to be
reinstated
[Music]
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
supreme court of the united states will
soon decide whether the death penalty is
back on the table for the man convicted
in the boston bombings
in 2013 dzhokhar tsarnaev and brother
tamerlan set off two bombs near the
finish line of the boston marathon in
the name of jihad
three people were killed including an
eight-year-old and hundreds of others
were wounded after that the brothers led
officials on a manhunt ending with
tamerlan dead in a police shootout after
dzhokhar ran him over with a vehicle
djihar was later arrested after hiding
out in a nearby boat djahar was
convicted in 2015 on 30 counts with a
recommended death penalty for six but in
july 2020 the u.s court of appeals for
the first circuit erased the capital
sentence the biden administration pled
its case to the justices on wednesday
asking to reverse the decision to vacate
dzhokhar's death penalty they argued
previous defenses that dzhokhar was
acting to please his older brother were
inaccurate saying he would have
committed the crimes even without
tamerlan
there was no evidence
that uh tamerlan physically intimidated
respondent to doing anything he was in
fact physically separate when he planted
his bomb and as for the influence
evidence as i've just said i think the
jury is much more likely to have found
this weight against respondent not as a
mitigating factor in his favor and let's
bear in mind that this is a jury who
heard evidence about the boat manifesto
the respondent wrote after he ran over
tamerlan in which he uh justified his
actions on the basis of jihad and showed
how proud he was of them that's after he
needn't worry about tamerlan at all in
fact he thought he was dying
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney julie randleman and terry
austin to see how they think scotus will
rule terry both former president trump
and president biden asked the supreme
court to reinstate the death penalty
does that create any pressure on the
justices and what do you think they'll
decide
i don't think it should create pressure
although it might it shouldn't be
decided by the political viewpoints of
any president or any legislator
authority other than the fact that it is
judicial president or the fact that
there is some sort of u.s constitutional
issue here the constitutional issue is
the fact that the trial court did not
allow questions to the jury to determine
whether or not they might have some bias
if they knew about the case so that's
the constitutional question here and i
think that the justices took the case
and it's an indication that they might
just reinstate the death penalty here
because otherwise
they could have just let the case go
back to the trial court to redetermine
that issue as far as the sentence was
concerned so we might see some change i
mean that makes a lot of sense to me
terry julie do you agree and where do
you think each judge will fall on this
issue
it's certainly strange when you have uh
biden and trump um administrations both
agreeing with reinstating so that can be
a bit confusing but at the end of the
day do i think they're going to that's
going to have an influence no i think
look it does usually divide and in this
case it seems to be dividing by party
lines in terms of at least the political
views the conservatives gorsuch alito
seem to be at least if it's a reflection
of the questions they are asking seem to
be leaning towards reinstating where you
have kagan
certainly as the leader
of some of the more liberal
supreme court justices leaning away from
it at the end of the day though um you
know the supreme court is mostly
conservative and it may very well go in
there in their favor in this case
absolutely i agree there thank you and
the federal judge in the elizabeth
holmes fraud trial says questionnaires
filled out by jurors could be released
to the public as former grocery store
and pharmacy leaders detail the
relationship with theranos
this week in the federal trial former
safeway ceo steve byrd took the stand
recalling a partnership the grocery
store chain shared with theranos the
company's plan to roll out theranosis
blood testing devices in more than 900
stores across 22 states but the rollout
never happened former walgreens cfo wade
mecalon testified to viewing a therino's
presentation that boasted 95 percent of
the blood test could be done on the
therinos edison device it would upload
results to the cloud with real-time
results but he later called the startup
quote disruptive technology meanwhile
judge edward davila told jurors the
answers to their once confidential
questionnaires may be released to the
public he specified jurors will be able
to review their answers before this and
meet with him and attorneys one on one
tuesday marked the start of week six in
the federal trial against a former
billionaire elizabeth holmes faces 12
counts of fraud in relation to the now
defunct theranos holmes claimed the
company would revolutionize blood
testing but later tests found many
issues with the devices
and nearly two decades after the
assassination of an assistant u.s
attorney the doj ups the reward money to
2.5 million dollars
thomas wales was shot in the back of the
neck in october 2001 in a seattle home
he is now known as the only federal
prosecutor in history to be a victim of
assassination officials say the suspect
stood in his backyard and fired several
shots through the basement window as
wales was on his computer after that the
shooter ran off on monday deputy
attorney general lisa monaco announced
that the justice department had
increased the reward for information
about the killer to two million dollars
saying the department of justice will
quote never forget tom's contributions
to the department and cause of justice
nor will it forget the tragedy of his
death
coming up on law and crime daily looking
ahead to the trial for the death of a
mod aubry breaking down the charges that
the defendants face plus the jury finds
mark gooch guilty in the murder and
kidnapping of sasha krauss what's next
for united states airmen after this
[Music]
welcome back the fate of mark gooch is
now sealed as a jury finds him guilty of
first degree murder and kidnapping in
the death of a mennonite woman sasha
krauss
on wednesday 22 year old mark gooch was
convicted of krause's murder she was
found dead in a forest outside flagstaff
arizona in february 2020. krauss was
last seen a month before in her village
near farmington new mexico at the time
gooch was stationed at an air force base
in phoenix but cell phone records show
he drove to krause's village the day she
went missing and his cell phone pinged
near the area where her body was later
found cross's cause of death was
determined to be blunt force trauma and
a gunshot wound to the head on friday
the jury began his deliberation after
hearing closing arguments from both the
defense and prosecution after two days
away from the courthouse the jury
reached a verdict wednesday afternoon
they found gooch guilty of first-degree
murder and kidnapping the judge also
ruled gucci was guilty of the theft of
krause's head covering and underwear
gooch now faces life in prison for his
crimes he is being held without bail
until a sentence hearing on november
24th
back to break down the verdict is
criminal defense attorney julie
randleman and co-host terry austin terry
do you agree with the verdict and was
today the day you thought we'd get a
verdict or did you think the jury would
need more time
brian i definitely agree with this
verdict there's no question that the
evidence was overwhelmingly against the
defendant and for the prosecution i
think that the jury came back in a
reasonable amount of time i don't think
they questioned much of what they heard
i think the only thing they might have
been considering is whether or not this
expert on the gun was right on the
defense side or correct on the
prosecution side but i think all the
rest of the evidence including the cell
phone pings on those towers convinced
the jury that it had to be gooch and he
was the one and the only one who was in
the area who had a motive and who
ultimately killed the victim now julie
did you expect a different verdict than
this and what do you expect income
sentencing
anyone you know who's been following
this case certainly i have was expecting
a very quick conviction i agree with
terry i think the only big issue was the
ballistics experts i thought the
ballistics expert for the prosecution
did a very poor job and i thought the
defense did a fantastic job i mean look
at the end of the day i believe the
sentence is going to be life without
parole um i think this is death penalty
eligible but they chose not to go that
route
and that's what he's going to get and
quite frankly based on the evidence in
this case that seems to be what he
deserves all right we'll see what
happens come sentencing when we come
back the charges that all three
defendants face for the shooting of a
mod arbory and hear from the lead
investigator what he concluded about the
incident in a pre-trial hearing stay
tuned to law and crime daily
[Music]
welcome back we continue to look ahead
to the trial for the death of a mod
arbory where three men stand charged
with his murder
ahmad aubry was a 25 year old unarmed
black man who was shot to death in
february 2020. arbor was out for a jog
in his georgia neighborhood when father
and son travis and gregory mcmichaels
pulled up in their pickup truck and
fired at him the incident was captured
on video by neighbor william bryan three
months later in may 2020 the father and
son were charged with felony murder in
connection to the shooting upon being
arrested the mcmichaels were both denied
bond two weeks later william bryan and
the mcmichael's neighbor was also
charged with felony murder and attempted
false imprisonment the arrest warrants
state that the neighbor tried to quote
confine and detain aubry without legal
authority before the jogger was shot at
a preliminary hearing in june 2020 the
judge ruled that there was enough
probable cause for the murder charges of
all three men this came after hours of
testimony from lead investigator who
gave his opinion on the self-defense
argument
i don't believe it was self-defense by
mr mcmichael i believe it was
self-defense by mr aubry
that's why he took the
once yes i believe mr albert was in
pursuit
and he randomly couldn't run anymore
and it would turn him back to a man with
a shotgun or
or fight with his bare hands against a
man with a shotgun he chose to fight
things to i believe mr aubrey's decision
was to just try to get away when he felt
like he could not escape
he chose to fight
julie malus murder felony aggravated
assault and unlawful imprisonment these
are the charges the big michaels and
brian face how does the prosecution
prove these charges
i think you know as a prosecutor i you
realize that the easiest charge and i i
hate to say easy because nothing's easy
is the felony
murder charges when it comes to the
false imprisonment because that is a way
to get each of those defendants in an
acting in concert capacity without
having to prove intent to kill it's just
the intent to do the um you know
basically you know by following him in
terms of the imprisonment so i think
that as a prosecutor i realize is the
easiest case the malice
murder is much tougher um it's obviously
the easiest it is is for travis
mcmichael he's the person that fired the
weapon he fired three times there's no
question that when someone fires a
weapon the intent is um to do something
pretty serious especially if you're
doing it and aiming it directly at a
person so i think that specific charge
is going to be much more difficult in
terms of proving that with the other two
defendants um and again yeah yeah now
terry the preliminary hearing is
probably what made the federal hate
crime case how much of the trial would
be about those two words traffic
mcmichael said over aubry as he died
those two words are going to be
extremely important brian there's no
question and we heard this from the
hearing that as aubry was dying travis
mcmichael stood over him with his
shotgun in his hand and said racial
slurs and there's also evidence that
there were racial slurs on the social
media of travis mcmichael and frankly
the prosecution is stating that all
three defendants have shown racial slurs
and have been prejudiced so i think it's
a good hate crime case absolutely and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you